what's up everybody my name is david
sebastian representing believe in
yourself records skid row fashion week
live from los angeles check me out on
the bootleg cab podcast uh
yo it's the bootleg podcast special
guest in here david sebastian what's
good uh what are you doing he's a rapper
he's an artist he's a uh an author
uh i mean how many hats are you wearing
you got clothing line
i'm wearing them all at the moment you
do literal art i'd say
definitely a musician uh
designer
uh author
um activist
um
philanthropist that's a big word for
saying you know you help out the
community right in some way
everything man i'm about to drop a
cookbook a raw vegan cookbook you know
so i guess i'm a chef now too so so
explain the raw
part because some people say they're
vegan but when i just talked to you
about it you were like no i eat
everything raw now so what does that
mean it's just electric foods you know
like a lot of times when you cook your
food over a certain um temperature you
cook out all the nutrients so
um it's something that's kind of new for
me but
i like it because you know your whole
life you you learn how to cook a certain
way right and then when you can't do
that anymore it forces your mind to
create new ways to do it and the the
cookbook thing was just like a lot of my
[ __ ] who like
in the hood don't know how to cook don't
know right yo rawls to expense like an
easy applicable way to make raw dishes
that look good that tastes good that
make you feel good for like under ten
dollars you know so is raw like
essentially you go to the store you buy
vegetables
and then you just eat them that way
yes but you don't just you don't just
take some collard greens just eat them
right so like a vegan dish would be i
mean a raw dish would be like you get a
collard green right and then you get
some hummus you put some hummus in it
you chop up some onions you put a little
dill on it you cut up some garlic uh you
add some uh
you know it's just playing with flavors
so then you roll that up i like make
this like raw sushi i roll it up and it
just tastes incredible man little sesame
seeds in it some as opposed to like
cooking
opposed to the food yeah i've lost
12 pounds in about two weeks oh that's
big and so this is something new you
just started i'm like 30 days in you
know i'm going to my birthday
because i love i love meat pause like i
love i love
i love me me too man you know that's why
i can never i just i i respect people
who say they're vegan yeah because i
couldn't i just can't even process
but it depends on how much you value so
when i eat meat and i'm like just a
[ __ ] carnivore i'm tired all the time
i'm [ __ ] sleeping in meetings i can't
move you know i mean i'm like in this
constant state of like narcosis right
so but i'm eating good
right but now i'm raw and it doesn't
really [ __ ] with like eating some ribs
or some jerk chicken but i stay up 19
hours out the day
i can run [ __ ] as long as i want to
you know i just feel incredible i feel
amazing are you good so after your
birthday you're gonna go back to eating
meat
no on my birthday i'm going to eat a
dish a dish a dish what would that dish
be
like some grated wagyu [ __ ] you know
just top maybe like thousand dollar
filet wagon
[ __ ] the wagoo's the one yeah that's the
wagon yeah that's a nice way to treat
yourself yeah um well listen you um you
came up on our show what like
march or april of last year yeah
killed your freestyle um
you put out some records um
you just put out a audio book yeah
called imagination time right yeah
um for people who don't know what that
means yeah explain to me the first of
all the inspiration
for this uh book um and
what is what does it mean
um
so the inspiration behind it was one of
my good friends uh jermaine he sent me
an audio book
maybe six seven years ago by a guy named
neville goddard who was a speaker a
positive speaker in the 40s and the 50s
and it changed my life it absolutely
changed my life and it all centered
around your imagination
essentially being god right so this
thing this entity this that we call god
is the human imagination right like if
you look around this room
what's one thing in here that wasn't
created by someone's imagination right
that's fair
the artwork the music in it the t it
you know everything is essentially
created by your imagination so this
audiobook
taught you how to utilize your
imagination
to create
the desired reality you want so i
started listening listening to it and
practicing it and then i was like oh
[ __ ] this is a book that's
old it's like it's old it's yeah from
the 40s i'm talking from 40s 50s it's on
youtube
typing how to use your imagination okay
it's brilliant so i started using it and
my life started changing because before
that
i did a lot of busy work i did a lot of
like you know sometimes we do a lot of
things to feel like we're doing
something
i was just always i'm doing this doing
this doing this
but once i learn the power of my
imagination
it's like you ever heard the expression
like a big dick don't gotta move that
much right right you know i mean you
don't got to do too much right you know
you can literally just think it and
create it into your reality so
long story short
just looking at all these teachers and
and philosophical people you got esther
hicks you got [ __ ] all these people
they're all like
older like white people you know they're
all like older white people and there's
no real representation in the audiobook
self-help space especially from someone
who's tattooed like me as a rapper and
in these streets you know so
really it just happened like that like
yo
i need to speak a language that my
people understand and then teach them
the power of their imagination so that's
how it started
yeah so like explain kind of
you said that during the pandemic you
had kind of started practicing yeah
this i guess
i guess imagination time yeah right so
kind of give people like a breakdown on
like what that entails and like so so
when you wake up
and before you go to sleep your your
mind enters something called rem sleep
right and
it's where
you don't really your subconscious
doesn't know the difference between a
dream and reality right
so that's the that's the best time to
impress upon thoughts in your mind that
you want to create because your
subconscious is going to materialize
them because they don't know if it's
real or if you're in a dream so i would
wake up and
at this time i was living at the orsini
do you know where the where city is is
that downtown it's downtown it's like
these hood projects you know like [ __ ]
was getting robbed and it's not like
[ __ ] uh the projects right right
it's like some it's like where like if
you're an upscale drug dealer you move
too and you know you get some like
luxury or whatever but i was in this one
bedroom and i just finished living in my
office which was an upgrade
and i wanted a penthouse man i wanted
a penthouse and i wanted a beautiful
[ __ ] girlfriend and i wanted
my music to go somewhere you know and i
wanted a record deal but i wanted the
right record deal i wanted real equity
and i wanted a couple other things that
i just wanted and i i started waking up
and i would go
i would spend i first started off at 10
minutes and i moved to 20 minutes and
then now i do 30 minutes a day
and what i would do is is i would lay
down
and i would put myself
in a situation
in the future
given that i had all the things that i
wanted so if i have the penthouse right
i'd envision me i closed my eyes and i'd
wake up in my mind
in that penthouse and i'd look outside
and i'd be like it's [ __ ] beautiful
up here and you know the girlfriend of
my dreams would be laying in the bed and
she'd be like you want me to cook you
some food and i'm like yeah cook me some
food and i'd walk around i'd get phone
calls about you know with my lawyer
talking like every you know you you
create it's just like a movie when you
write a script you're writing a script
for your future life right right right
and then you live in that reality
and then you let it go
you just wake up and go about your day
you don't worry if it's gonna happen you
don't worry why it's not happening you
don't even worry about the current
reality and you just let it go like you
just watched the film
and then crazy shit's just gonna start
happening to you man i've seen it happen
to me i've seen it happen to my friends
i've seen it happen to my mom who
practices it now and
you know one thing led to another it's
the pandemic i'm like [ __ ] everybody's
on their phones now something said yo
drop your album i'm like drop my album
but how am i going to upload it to this
and i can't do it uh sell it on your
website i'm like selling on my [ __ ]
website okay [ __ ] it
end up making
too much money and then end up
leveraging that into you know a
situation a situation and the the great
situation and then i end up getting that
[ __ ] penthouse and end up meeting
this girl who i'm not with anymore but i
think i met her the last time you give
me her yeah she was fine she was a
beautiful human being she was nice yeah
very nice
she was fine and she was nice
but um that didn't work out because um
you know you ever heard the saying be
careful what you asked for
definitely
you know you you may think you want
something but you have to be very very
specific on what you want because you
might end up getting exactly what you
say you want
that's fair
yeah well you also um
this penthouse you had was
there was a very
bad situation that happened for people
who don't know well it wasn't at this
point
of that penthouse and moved to another
penthouse so where you moved for people
who don't know there was a uh in la
there was a hostage situation yeah
that everyone across the world saw on
online yeah
where they they
there was was it your lady that was
being held hostage she was my friend
your friend was being held hostage at
your place by a guy a gunman correct and
the police the swat team whatever it is
blew blew the wall up or and then
rescued her
yeah killed the dude killed the guy in
your living room you're not home at the
time no you wanted to know something
that's crazy is um
that was [ __ ] crazy it was very cuz i
was watching and then i saw you post
like that's my home and i was like oh
[ __ ] the thing that's crazy is is i
threw a little party the night before
and um a couple people stayed over and
whatever and and my friend her name's
haley the one who got um held it
gunpoint
before i left to go to a meeting right
i said don't let no weird don't don't
let no weird crazy [ __ ] in my house i
don't know why i said it i just looked
back i was like don't let no weird crazy
[ __ ] in my house and she laughed she's
like i'm not and i'm like okay cool
and then i leave and i go to this
meeting
and then i'm like calling her trying to
reach out to her and she's not picking
up and i and i'm like that's strange
like why she's not picking up maybe
she's asleep right right right and then
we get back to my house and um
the entire street is [ __ ] blocked off
everything is blocked off from here to
[ __ ] 7th street or whatever and i'm
like what's going on and people like yo
it was the shooting it was a shooting
she was shooting i'm like oh [ __ ] you
know this is crazy it's like the gunman
ran into your building now i'm like oh
[ __ ] he's in my building now it's like
crazy
calling her she's still not picking up
and something in my gut was like oh [ __ ]
i bet this nigga's in my house only
because crazy [ __ ] happens to me like
this crazy movie weird [ __ ] just happens
and i'm like there's no reason why she
wouldn't be picking up with this this
and i put two and two together and then
um
someone who i was with
uh
i don't well just someone i was with uh
was just like i think someone's in your
house and i'm like uh
oh [ __ ] someone is in my house
so the guy had a bad day
he went on a [ __ ] shooting rampage
tried to steal a car shot someone
pulled the trigger at another dude's
head the gun one click
ended up running into my building and uh
running into my house and your friend's
okay
she's okay i mean outside of the outside
of the drama that's trump this situation
but she's alive you know which is
amazing but you know anything could have
happened and then when they broke in you
know he grabbed her to shield himself
and
it could have went really bad it could
have went really really bad um so when
they
because there was like an explosion
right
yeah they put c4 on all my doors they
blew they blew up my crib they like blew
up my crib my closet that [ __ ] is like
horrible
so all the [ __ ] that i manifested ended
up getting blown up
which is funny as [ __ ] which is crazy
personal belongings [ __ ] yeah but a
lot of them
but none of it means anything right it
really doesn't and i can honestly say
that to anybody probably watching this
like
you know you you work your whole life to
get new cars and watches and clothes and
clothes and [ __ ]
but they really don't mean anything i
agree man yeah i tell people all the
time are you do you still live there
hell no i don't know they owe me money
too santa fe also owes money if you're a
lawyer watching this i have a million
dollar civil case ready to go
get at me because seriously they update
who owes you money the apartment
building or the cops
all of them okay everybody
yeah they kind of blew up your your
i mean insurance
the building because the dude shouldn't
have been able to get into the building
there was a security guard that wasn't
on he was working that day but he was
always hollering at women like every
time on netflix or something yeah he was
like
every time i see a guy working security
at a building he's got his phone like
underneath the desk he's got a little
earplug yeah yeah he ain't [ __ ]
tripping so he should never been able to
get in that building you know let alone
up to the fourth floor oh the fourth
floor yeah yeah that's a
that's not like a yeah yeah yeah like
so well at least that your friend's fine
yeah you know physically she's still
here yeah
when you saw that like
what are you what are your thoughts
what's your reaction because i went into
imagination time i swear to god when
when
bombs were going off guns was going off
my friends were crying i literally
closed my eyes and i envisioned her
being dragged out of the building alive
i used all of my energy and i didn't
worry everybody else was scared as [ __ ]
i wasn't scared i said she's coming and
that's how you utilize your imagination
you can heal yourself you can heal
someone else you can manipulate a
situation simply by seeing the outcome
and then believing it i guess that's
what people would call faith
manifestation manifestation
faith yeah do you think um
would you kind of compare the
imagination time thing to like a form of
meditation in a way of course yeah yeah
it's a focus it's a practice yeah um i
saw that jim carrey had tapped in with
the audiobook he said that one of his
friends had shared it with him
um and then he tweeted about it yeah
which is a big deal by the way jim
carrey's probably got one of the more
incredible imaginations ever yo did you
hear him on uh the weekend's new album
yeah
it's genius the whole
radio station is genius yeah the
weekend's album is dope i [ __ ] with it
um but not just that's gotta be crazy
right like
jim carrey tweeting about you
i'm blessed i have so much yo i have
something i can't even talk about that's
gonna happen with jim carrey that uh
it'll probably surface in a couple weeks
something
collaborative collaborative yeah music
i don't know
that's fair that's big
have you met jim carrey yeah
cool dude
psychedelic electric delic he seems like
i know he does art and he paints and
stuff like he seems like a very uh yeah
he was he's always been my favorite
actor i love the truman show i love um
man on the moon everything that he's
done has been just yeah remarkable but
um
i got a lot of [ __ ] up my sleeve this
year i'm [ __ ] swinging for the fences
man
goodwill collaboration
yeezy skid row collaboration
you're gonna you're collaborating with
yeezy on skid row i don't know i just
coughed i don't know what's going on
but uh a lot a lot of a lot of
transitions a lot of new things are
happening
i'm dropping eight projects this year
eight yeah now when you say projects
music music projects
yeah eight bodies of work in some
capacity this year valentine's day times
i made girls cry in december dropping ai
artificial ignorance throughout the
summer i'm dropping mixed tapes in texas
new orleans canada chicago something to
go to these regions and work with manny
fresh and new orleans if different
producers
re-releasing we are god uh there will be
blood which will be a christmas album
that i do on skid row using people from
the community to make like the craziest
christmas album ever wow
yo it's you know it's interesting
because like you have like um like you
said you're you give back a lot but you
also shine a light on skid row and just
kind of the homeless population in
general in l.a yeah and i feel like
during the pandemic um
i guess homelessness obviously was on a
rise but it also kind of became like the
national narrative about la's going to
[ __ ] because the homeless there's people
sleeping everywhere it's like
you know the city can fix this watch i
was going to ask you kind of your take
on that because you're you know you're
probably so just like death right death
is a trillion dollar business death
so is
uh fitness
so is homelessness
if there was no homelessness then there
wouldn't be these foundations to help
homelessness which are everyone's got
salaries where everyone's got these
overfluff salaries and
it's like a business you know you got to
feed this and the tax write offs and all
this [ __ ] you know so they kind of need
it to exist
um
and mind you
there are some people living on skid row
who want to live on skid row
like you know not everyone wants to live
in a house there's a story of this woman
who we got housing for
moved into her house and then set up her
tent in her living room
threw away all the furniture in the
house and set up her tent in the middle
of her living room
jesus shout out to her
dedicated it's dedicated but um
so my goal isn't to necessarily
eradicate skid row for everyone because
i feel like there are people who are
simply who simply want to be
liberated from society who don't want
any fiduciary responsibility
but
the people who do want to get out of it
like i've been doing imagination time on
skid row going up certain people and
getting them to see what they imagine
and 10 out of 10 of them are just
imagining a nice place to sleep
they're like man i just want to live in
a living room with a nice couch into
this and some pajamas they're just they
just want somewhere to sleep and an
opportunity there's thousands and
thousands and thousands of square foot
square footage in factories downtown
that are vacant
that i'm going to buy
i'm going to buy i'm going to turn it
into housing i'm also going to
branch it off into my skid row
manufacturing there should be skin road
uh
trash cleanup we're going to start a
community garden there's you know skid
row potato chips because you can grow
potatoes up and i have this whole plan
of you know getting a potato factory and
then making skid row potato chips and
like i'm just i'm just uh
figuring it out did you notice skid row
getting becoming a more like or downtown
just in general becoming a more wild
place the last two years
yeah i know it was always it always was
wild in pockets but it felt like it's
getting crazy man it's feeling like
gotham city right now every time i go
downtown
it's like
it's like i'm like every time i go it's
like damn shit's getting crazy and then
i'll go two months later it's like [ __ ]
i'll go a week later but the crazy thing
is is on skid row it's not crazy man i
feel safer on skid row than
on melrose right melrose yeah yeah mel
rose's it's hot for sure melrose didn't
used to be like that
yeah of course yeah you know but like
skid row is really a community of
[ __ ] people like it's really like
grandmama's grand uncles cousins it's
like a it's a community yeah there's
some junkies yeah there's some this but
it's really good people man
yeah do you um do because with your
interactions with people on skid row
because i always feel like
with the homeless thing there's there's
like you said there's people who
are there because they don't have a
choice so they want to get out of it
they want to get right into a better
place and then there are a fraction of
the people who have drug problems who
have mental problems right who
you know
not even talking about the people who
just want to be liberated from society
but people who just
are in a position where
they might have addiction that they're
dealing with
um
do you feel like
like what do you think is the solution
for those people psychedelics
just give everyone some shrooms some
ayahuasca
not just give it to them and say here
take this but
you know something that i want to create
is i want to i want to create an
environment
where people going through addiction and
trauma
can be inducted into a program
where their diet is all raw fruits raw
vegetables
and they micro dose shrooms and
dmt and ayahuasca
and they go on an inward journey into
their psyche and i believe that you can
help cure
a lot a lot yeah
i think ayahuasca is like the one thing
that like i know people who have had um
lifelong addiction yeah they've had
vices that they could never shake
they've had
suppressed mental stuff that they never
even knew was the reason why they were a
certain way yeah because it forces you
to like have you done ayahuasca yeah
yeah
and when i've i
for me everyone's experiences did you do
it with a shaman yeah yeah
um
i'm a shaman
are you yeah well no
yeah okay
um but uh you're an ayahuasca shaman i'm
just a shaman in general
in life i respect that okay yeah
but um
these drugs
are not
these met this medicine i don't even
want to call it a drug but
it helps you look at yourself this
character that you created for yourself
and
for me i looked at all the things that
made me me and
i don't know man it's just
when i took dmt for the first time i
seen these little elves these mechanical
elves they were just like laughing at me
i was like in this whole like mechanical
realm and they were just like laughing
and
it made me feel like
in this other dimension somewhere
there's people they're just laughing at
us because we're just [ __ ]
trivial yeah we're just so trivial we're
like working our whole lives at jobs we
[ __ ] hate to buy [ __ ] we don't need
and things are [ __ ]
yeah yeah and just like in fear and [ __ ]
and they're just like hahaha like you
know like life is so [ __ ] simple
it really is man and
you know i i wear nice [ __ ]
not because i feel like it brings my
value up or to get girls or to look cool
but i genuinely
um i love this i'm a fan of aesthetics
you know i love nice [ __ ]
but it doesn't define me man i've got
i'll give i give [ __ ] away i don't give
a [ __ ] you know
yeah um what for when you did ayahuasca
how did that like what was that
experience like for you because you know
sometimes people puke they [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] i mean it's for people who who
don't know it's like a process it's not
like you just you get the shivers you
get the shakes you i mean it's like d
it's like detoxing it's like when you're
going through a uh what do you call it a
heroin withdrawals and [ __ ] you know
um
[Music]
i i've heard people say that like
there's like a voice you hear
or like are you going to the astroplane
you're floating in nothingness you're
going through a black hole i mean me i
don't know what anyone else is going but
your time stops it just
there is no time there is no nothing
you're like one with everything
that's crazy and you know obviously for
people who don't know it's it's like
something you drink you know i don't
think i think people for the most part
probably know about shrooms they
probably know about dmt i think
ayahuasca is the one thing that's like
not as easily as accessible i think it
might be it's pretty in the future i
think it's going to be something more
people tap into but
can you imagine that creating some type
of process on skid row where people
where people are introducing yeah
because i do think that that is a way
that people can really kick real
addiction yeah yeah you know it's like
addiction is like especially the
certain [ __ ] is like
physically
hard just to just just to do because you
know if i quit doing this
then i got a week of the worst pain in
my life coming my way so i'm just gonna
keep doing it yeah and there's no like
i guess you know i think that that's
probably
one of the bigger reasons why like
people end up homeless
like it is what it is like you know
being a drug addict is a full-time job
they say being an addict to anything is
a full-time job yeah you treat it like
it's like your job every day to get high
or to
whatever whatever that thing is yeah i
um
yeah i i agree yeah um so so you know i
wanted to ask you man cause like i feel
like here in l.a
you're like one of the dopest minds we
have thank you i feel like you
your music is incredible i feel like
everything you you do is dope but like
for whatever reason i feel like you're
still somehow underappreciated in the
hip-hop community when we think of
l.a i just made you say this i was
thinking about this and you just said
it's interesting that's crazy um why do
you think that is and do you give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ]
um but
why do i think it is
huh so
music is on a frequency right just like
the radio station right
life is all about frequencies right
you know when you you can't get you
can't get things up you can't get things
that you get when you vibrate up here if
you're vibrating down here right
so music as a gener as a whole
is kind of vibrating at this frequency
right here right
and in order for it to stay at this
frequency
only artists and music and thought
processes
that allow that frequency to thrive it
so it stays here when when it's here
it's safe it's a lot of money to be made
right it's a lot of my i mean i could
get really deep with you but
you know
um
music is religion
music is religion it's like when you go
to a concert it's like going to church
you know
uh our bodies are
90 water music vibration sounds
especially 808s which uh resonate with
our lower chakras it can control us it
can manipulate us it can influence us so
right now music is like right here
and our people
are being
controlled influenced and manipulated at
this frequency
now this guy named david sebastian this
entity right here
he's he's he's he's vibrating up here
and the second that that vibration
becomes popular
it's gonna force everyone down here to
rise
and now the subject matters are gonna
change and now the what we deem is
important isn't going to be and now
you're going to have a group of
people
self-actualizing and asking themselves
questions and saying why do i need to
buy that or why am i that earned i don't
want to [ __ ] go to the club today
it's it's like a whole new paradigm
shift
and when that paradigm shift exists
a lot of the [ __ ] down here
just will become irrelevant it's kind of
like
remember ja rule was like the biggest
[ __ ] on planet earth and then 50 cent
came out and then and then he wasn't and
then he just wasn't yeah because 50
created a new paradigm
kanye shifted the paradigm she did he
kind of shifted it away from 50. exactly
shifted away from 50.
so every now and then you have these
paradigm shifters
it was very hard i was talking to dame
about this very very hard for dame dash
yeah damn damn i was talking to dame
and it was hard for jay-z to get
anywhere no label would sign them nobody
wanted them
right same with kanye we hear about his
struggles
sometimes when you have a new
perspective
and you're in and and it's and it's and
it's more futuristic than anyone can
currently see it's always going to be a
tumultuous thing to get to where you
need to be yeah it's like the
it's the harder journey but it's the
more fruitful journey once you get there
it's like
like you could dumb your [ __ ] down or
you could do what everyone else is doing
and you could play industry games and
worry about
all that [ __ ] but at the end of the day
like i could start a tick tock i could
do a cool dance i could do all that but
you know what what i'm doing right now
what i'm building right now
is i'm building a legacy
this is legacy right i had a waitress
come up to me who i didn't even know and
she was like
my son loves you he's like seven years
old i play him all of your music i show
them all of your art my entire family's
rooting for you we want you to like
someone swear to god like yesterday
someone hit me was like david i've been
following you from the jump since [ __ ]
marijuana and i somehow got out of
contact with you and found your
instagram and you were at 70 000
followers and i got really mad and i was
like i got she was like i got really
[ __ ] mad and she was like because
like the output you put out and the
level of work and consistency and blah
blah blah like you should have a million
plus [ __ ] 20 million followers and
then i then she was like i realized how
this system
is man so
i'm not mad because i know what's going
to happen this year
some major
major things are about to change with me
being at the forefront of culture
and um
yeah so it's just a matter of time yeah
i think like too like i feel like you
are building your own ecosystem your own
world almost yeah as to where like most
artists who come into this game they're
very much dependent on
you know going to grammy parties and
networking and
you know just doing whatever they got to
do just to kind of but i feel like
you're kind of over here building your
island
and eventually
you know people are gonna come to your
island and then yeah and then hopefully
the music industry starts to look a lot
more like your island so just i want to
paint a quick picture for you
imagine if
david sebastian
number one record on the on the
billboard right
which means that there's a lot of eyes
on what i'm doing right
imagine i i have a skid row drop this
friday right with millions of eyes on me
yo we're we're dropping this skid row
collaboration
and then that drop makes two million
dollars
and then i take all of that two million
dollars and i put that into building my
factories out and employing the homeless
and then i drop imagination time and
instead of 20 30 000 people hearing it
now it's millions of people hearing it
and now you have millions of people
having imagination time every morning
and every night and while that's
happening this like it's it's going to
be a phenomena
yeah hey listen i don't doubt it man
i i look forward to looking back at this
interview
oh this is these these are the
interviews
like like i hate to say nip because i'm
not like putting this with death or
anything of course of course of course
but like but no we go back and we watch
old nipsey yeah you watch it i remember
when he died i went back and watched old
nipsey interviews that i've never seen
before and i was like damn this thing he
was always talking that [ __ ] he was
talking that [ __ ]
that's facts man that's facts like i
think nipsey like was
for whatever reason like ahead of his
time but also like
you know of i wish i wish he was here to
see
the love that he's got now because like
i've you know i've been knowing nipseys
and split 09 is when i first met him
yeah um
he was on my show in 2009 and like
you know he was always like
like one of our guys like we you know
i'm a [ __ ] hip-hop head so like i was
rooting for nipsey but like just to see
like the love and like he's become an
icon you know what i'm saying an icon
downtown there's a thousand nipsey
murals everywhere you know there's a
saying
that great men
plant seeds
for trees
for shade for great men plant seeds for
trees that they won't be able to sit
under its shade or something
yeah that makes sense you know like
it sucks because i mean
in the physical for him to see the
amount of reverence
you know and and i know i'm going i'm
going to see it in this lifetime
i came here
for a reason for a purpose
and um i think we need liberation more
than anything
the world needs to be liberated
culture needs to be liberated we we've
been in the box for too long and i think
kovid
has has made a lot of people take inward
journeys in you know i i think
i think kovid aside from
the obvious deaths that have come of
course of course but i think it was a
blessing for a lot of people as well
yes because it forced you to sit by
yourself
i have this song called running with the
wolves where i asked a girl when was the
last time you were truly happy when you
were all by yourself and you weren't at
a party like we numb ourselves with with
devices
experience going to the club going to
the bar dopamine [ __ ] drivers yeah
yeah yeah but what if you're alone at
home yeah for a year or six months or
whatever it is yeah man it's [ __ ]
because like everyone i know is
depressed right now
a lot of i mean that is the one thing
about kovac like my kid uh who's in high
school he was like we had to put him in
counseling and stuff because like
he was just
going through it with his girlfriend and
[ __ ] with his mom and like
but it was like he couldn't leave his
house he didn't have interaction with
his friends
he was sitting in front of a computer
every day for [ __ ] six hours
you know it's different everyone i sit
in front of lately i've been having
lunches and everyone's just like breaks
down mid-conversation
and
you know
i try to do my best to help or try to
inspire as much as i can but
i honestly think it's a good thing i
think it's a good thing do you know you
got to go through it at some point it's
self-reflection and you know when you
come out of it you come out of it
stronger but we are in a very serious
place in the world
did you end up catching covet ever no no
shout out to you
you know what's funny
and this might sound like some weird
superhuman weirdness i never caught
kovid but i was in atlanta and i was
shooting a radio interview and this is
when kobe was going around and i woke up
and i couldn't breathe
i had the shakes hot cold sweats were
like for sure i got it i have covet
i went in the bath i turned on hot water
and i had imagination time and i
imagined that you didn't have it the
sickness just coming out of my pores and
into the water
and
literally an hour later i was perfectly
fine did the interview
no cough no nothing interesting i was
just [ __ ] great imagination time for
people who don't know
they can get the audio book but they um
it's super simple they could just if you
got zell cash app venmo apple pay so
hopefully by the time this this airs
yeah it'll be on audible and it'll be on
uh
amazon right but right now uh
go to uh
you could text me right yo it's crazy
when i drop weird god i did the same
method text me send me the cash app and
literally imagination time i have
thousands of text messages in my phone
right now you have a separate phone no
oh this is my my line wow
and you is your is your number up on
your yeah yeah it's 917-535-8577
so if you hear this and you want it you
can just text me like y'all want the
audio and it's like um
seven chapters or six seven seven
chapters yeah
it's an easy listen right very easily
it's me composing the whole thing
playing the piano it's kind of an
experience like if you're gonna check it
out you should probably
be relaxed yeah in april i'm dropping
another audio book and it's called
believe in yourself and it's more of a
episodic of
how i got to this point from dropping
out of high school to becoming a
freelance designer to traveling with
steve aoki and designing his brand of
this and to working with drake on his
planes and this and that and just to how
i got to this point it's called believe
in yourself so we're going to get to
some of that but i got to take a piss so
quick intermission and then we'll be
right back yo stop at the interview got
to tell you about our good folks at odd
socks man listen go to odd socks
official.com use the promo code 20 off
save 20 off some of the craziest socks
you know they got the ninja turtle
joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks
basics these are my boys right here i
love these right here you get the plain
black the plain white very comfortable
most comfortable socks in the world to
be honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheez-it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all listen man put
the mod socks on your ass cheeks and
thank me later
yeah i didn't even see that you had
posted this kanye thing yeah so you
posted this yesterday right
so you and kanye this there's like a
official collaboration between yeezy and
skid row it's not official to he posted
but there's some things in the works how
did he reach out to you or how did that
happen
um
i can't even really talk about that
right now after real i promise you when
i can i'm gonna come back here i'm gonna
give you the whole school okay okay okay
yeah that's i mean you po you put it out
there
yeah but it was a question mark it was
like is this is what's happening here
you know um
talk to me how you ended up working on
the drake plane [ __ ]
um
a good friend of mine matt babel who
manages drake
uh back when i was having some tough
times and i need some money he hired me
to do freelance design work for ovo and
for a dream crew and their whole [ __ ]
and i just used to just design shirts
merch whatever whatever they needed
and uh he put that on my desk it was
like drake just has a plan you have any
ideas and
i had a shoe called air david you know
and i was just like if he tight like if
i had a plane and called my [ __ ] air
david
i was like [ __ ] i'm probably gonna have
a jet anytime soon i was i just kind of
gave the idea heir drake you know just
and then you know he has the nike thing
so it's like instead of just do it
i did it you know like
so um i just kind of slid that
conceptually when it comes to like
design i feel like there's a few
underappreciated people when it comes to
our industry
cameraman photographers and graphic
designers being like at the top of the
list for sure i feel like most graphic
designers always get underpaid or people
expect them to do something for free or
they'll put a whole lot of work in on a
design they'll submit it and then if the
artist don't like it they might never
even hear heard from them again yeah um
it depends on how you build i mean i was
that for a couple years but now i get i
started off in this game i got a hundred
dollars per design
then after teenage millionaire i went up
to 300 to design
and then i started working with steve
aoki and doing diesel and ruka and then
i went up to 500 to design
and then i started working with von
dutch and pakistan and blah blah blah
and that went up to like 900 to design
and then blah blah blah now i'm i'm i
won't touch it if i'm not getting you
know
15 to 2 000 a design and some type of
equity in the piece and it's like i was
going to say like do you have any advice
for people who do graphics who are
trying to figure out how to
differentiate stop doing graphics and do
graphics for yourself
just make your own [ __ ] make your own
[ __ ] and then make people respect you
and then then charge them then then you
can set your price
because if you're a graphic designer
like you said like
they really treat you like the
underbelly of [ __ ] when you're when
you're it's your ideas and designs that
are creating these [ __ ] brands so
you know create something for yourself
build a business around it make
something out of it and then people will
start coming to you like can you do this
and you can set your own price
on the clothing [ __ ] like was what were
some of the trial and error things you
had to kind of get through to like
really because you know clothing is a
very it's a tough business to be in
there's a lot of overhead depending on
how you do it you know there's certain
people who i mean transparently i'm
currently going through a problem
because
i have like 3 000 orders unfulfilled
because
you know we're
we're teaching people we're taking
people off the street and we're
essentially teaching them how to screen
print right so that's a whole thing in
itself
but then
when you have 30 40 skus on a website
and people want 100 of these but 20 of
these and 30 of these then you got to
print these and this and then shipping
and this it's like a whole thing so
i just uh shut down the skid row site
just for a couple weeks
shipping everyone their [ __ ] out and i
brought in a new manager to help run the
business and
um yeah so you're going through that as
we speak yeah yeah going through it as
we speak because
you know you won a million orders you
want people to spend you know a million
but how are you going to [ __ ] ship a
million dollars worth of product you
know what i mean so
expansion growth
we talked a little bit about you know
how we i feel like you're underrated in
in lac and who are some of the artists
that you grew up listening to that you
feel like never really got their their
full flowers
in la
um
i don't know i mean i the people i grew
up listening to park i grew up listening
to jay
wayne you know like i there's like
nip uh let's say nip
i'll say nip
because nip was a purveyor of taste and
he had that thing and he had the spark
and he made great music and he was for
the cultures for his hoodies for the
people he made good music and uh
it was only
through his posthumous death that he was
fully appreciated fully appreciated but
yeah um
i've never seen a me before though i've
never seen a [ __ ] who do all this [ __ ]
i've done and has indirectly and
directly affected culture who hasn't
gotten his flowers yet
say 12 months from now i'm talking to
you let's manifest some [ __ ] what do you
hope what do you where do you hope to be
where do you hope to have happened this
year man
um
number one across the board and
everything skid row manufacturing
gross 50 million dollars employed in
house thousands of people
music number one hit single album
touring across the board sold out
audio books my publishing company
number one on amazon
my kids program just draw it building
the school
here in new york chicago my art and the
louvre the the moma the mocha you know
going for 200 i'm about to do an art
exhibition that's why i mentioned matter
of fact i'm gonna show you something
i've been working on it um i'm doing an
art exhibition
next month my first time doing these
like 20-foot artworks
so you can't really see how big these
are but this is like 25 feet oh that's
fire
they have like real hair
oh [ __ ]
now if somebody wanted to
this
that's crazy how big this is
what are you saying i was gonna say
hypothetically speaking someone wants to
buy one of these what is it what does a
25 foot piece of art go for from david
sebastian that's a lot so like
i feel like look how big this is
oh yeah that's massive that's fire so
this i think i haven't uh it's going to
be about 150 000
wow yeah
what it like when you
painting and making art like that is
like you gotta have inspiration like
what is it like
is it something that like how often are
you working on pieces
every morning four o'clock in the
morning i have a regimen four
to nine eight four to nine in the
morning i'm painting nine to three i'm
doing business
three to seven i'm shooting content
seven to eleven or twelve i'm making
music so you're sleeping three or four
hours a day kind of yeah
i'd be up with my videographer esko at 3
30 in the morning
talking [ __ ] all day just working do you
feel like um have you always had that
kind of like those sleep habits
yes yes i lo i honestly like i love
and if you're listening this you should
try it because spiritually
the veil is thinnest at three o'clock in
the morning there's an energy while
everyone is asleep like it's like um
it's like cpu power in your [ __ ]
computer right while everyone's awake
all the energy and everything is being
distributed evenly but when
[ __ ] are asleep you can just my
best ideas my best songs my everything
happens three in the morning four in the
morning
so you feel like um what because i feel
like most people would think you need
eight hours of sleep i know a lot of
people like usually i get about six six
to seven but i mean you say you're
rolling on four hours of sleep we don't
need anything
we have been conditioned and told as a
as a human race that we need this and we
need that and we need this or we're
going to be deficient in this and you
need this so we believed it and that
belief system is what
perpetuates the need for that we need
eight hours of sleep so you need hours
of sleep and if you don't have it then
you feel the the elves of that you don't
need [ __ ] you are you are a [ __ ] god
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and be completely fine
ladies and gentlemen that is david
sebastian yeah and he's got uh well just
so we're clear
people can go support the audio book
when when you're on audible text me
917-535-8577
if you want to be a part of this
community this tribe that i'm building
text 310-388-5193
if you want to buy some skill real [ __ ]
go to skidrowfashionweek.com
or pull up to the warehouse on pico and
uh maine uh 1300 south main that's where
the skid row office is
um if you want to be a part of the team
and you want to help expand this hit
careers believe in yourselfrecords.com
you know that's the label if you got a
book and you want to get published you
know my [ __ ] read books too publishing
that's mine um
i love that
and then eight projects of music coming
we even talk about the music valentine's
day times i made girls cry april
re-release the weird god
june uh atlanta georgia nano some some
here this is the
also got a little calendar of all the
this year i ain't [ __ ] around man
oh i see it yeah and you got all the
artwork already done i got the albums
done everything is done
is it harder for you to do that while
being
a quote unquote on a major label or is
that part of the deal that you worked
out this part i mean they're my partners
i'm not signed to this okay
joint jv situation but um
listen man
this is this is where you kind of zoom
into the camera you get into my face i
look at this right here
um
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do okay
you could fly if you believe it
in order to know you can fly you got to
jump first that's how a bird learns it
can fly because the [ __ ] kicks
it out the nest and it falls and then it
either fly or die right and all i'm
doing is spreading my wings
if you're not going to give it to me
i don't need a co-sign i don't need none
of that [ __ ]
at the end of the day i am waking up
people one at a time and all of this is
going to create
um
this cosmic shift
of energy within our people man i'm
gonna put on the illest shows
without a label it's not even about a
label how self-funnest i'm gonna put on
the illa shows drop the illest visuals
drop the illest music the illest merch
at the same god damn time
gap goodwill collapsed i wanna show you
something don't say it online but yo
look at this
hollywood unlock is dropping
this oh
what
me who
it's a rap
there it is go follow him man yeah
thank you thank you for this interview
thank you for letting me freestyle and
oh good man please invite me back
anytime i would love to come there it is
go follow this guy go support him david
sebastian